[Musik]
die Nachrichten des Tages heute mit
Mitri Sirin schönen guten Abend den
sportlichen Teil übernimmt heute wieder
Kristin Otto ja Freude Enttäuschung und
auch Trauer bei uns guten Abend dann
schauen wir jetzt gemeinsam auf die
Themen
Unterstützung für die Ukraine auf der
Münchner Sicherheitskonferenz fordert
Kanzler Scholz mehr Panzer und Präsident
silensky mehr Geschwindigkeit
Angst vor Seuchen in den
Erdbebengebieten in der Türkei und
Syrien droht die nächste Katastrophe
Angriff auf Polizisten vor einem Trierer
Club gehen dutzende Randalierer auf die
Einsatzkräfte los
[Musik]
wenn der Luft Raum über Münchens Zentrum
gesperrt wird und 4.500 Polizeikräfte im
Einsatz sind ist wieder
Sicherheitskonferenz bis Sonntag
diskutieren unter anderem 45
Staatsoberhäupter und Regierungschefs
über die weltweit angespannte
Sicherheitslage Brandherde gibt es
genügend der Fokus liegt aber ganz klar
auf dem Ukraine Krieg mattes fällt auf
berichtet
es ist ein emotionaler Auftakt der
Münchner Sicherheitskonferenz zu den
Klängen von Franz Schubert sind noch mal
die Bilder von 358 Tagen Krieg zu sehen
aus Kiew zugeschaltet erinnert Präsident
selenski daran dass nicht nur die
Ukraine Ziel der russischen Aggression
sei
während wir unsere Verteidigung mit
modernen Panzern Stärken denkt der
kremme längst darüber nach wie er Moldau
unter Druck setzen kann
zwei Tage lang geht es darum wie die
Ukraine am besten unterstützt und dieser
Krieg am schnellsten beendet werden kann
zum Auftakt mahnt Bundeskanzler Olaf
Scholz die gerade gegebenen Versprechen
gegenüber der Ukraine einzuhalten lange
hatte stolz gezögert bei der Lieferung
von Kampfpanzern nun führt er plötzlich
die sogenannte panzerkoalition an und
wähnt sich ziemlich allein in dieser
entscheidenden Frage gilt Sorgfalt vor
Schnellschuss Zusammenhalt vor solo
Vorstellung
und es gilt unsere Unterstützung von
Anfang an so anzulegen dass wir sie
lange durchhalten dazu gehört das alle
die solche kampfanze liefern können
diesen auch wirklich tun und auch
Frankreichs Präsident fordert weitere
Unterstützung für die Ukraine
wir müssen den Ukrainern helfen und
Unterstützung intensivieren damit sie
eine Gegenoffensive führen können damit
es dann Verhandlungen geben kann deren
Bedingungen die Ukraine wählt die Grenze
so dritte ist und der Westen rückt
zusammen und wappnet sich dafür die
Sicherheit in Europa neu zu organisieren
zu Thomas Reichert nach München was ist
das politische Ziel des Westens bei der
Konferenz
also man hat den Eindruck dass die Welt
sich hier neu sortiert neu ausrichtet
gegenüber Putin es ist für den Westen
erstmal so eine Selbstvergewisserung
schließlich wird ja gleichzeitig hier
auch darum gerungen insbesondere unter
den Europäern wer denn nun wann wie
viele Panzer liefert aber auffallen ist
schon wie hier auch geworden wird um den
sogenannten globalen Süden und Länder
wie Brasilien Indien oder Südafrika die
noch nicht per se zu antibooting Allianz
gehören sie sollen Teil werden in einem
Club der auf die Macht des Rechte setzt
schon auf die Macht der stärkeren und
das ist vielleicht so eine Art kleinster
gemeinsame Nenner um Russland zu
isolieren und auch eine Art Warnung an
das große China dass ihr damit droht
sich Taiwan einzuleiten die Reaktion
allerdings auf diese Club Einladung die
waren jetzt erstmal nicht so
überschwänglich
dann vielen Dank für die Einschätzung
nach München Thomas Reichert ja und
während die internationale
Sicherheitspolitik über mögliche Auswege
vor allem aber über weitere Waffenhilfe
für die Ukraine berät wird in der
Ostukraine weiter erbittet gekämpft der
freie Journalist Arndt Genzel war nahe
der Frontlinie bei bachmut Franziska von
tiesenhausen fast die Bilder zusammen
Konstantin Eva keine 30 km westlich von
bachmut hierhin kommen viele Soldaten
nach einem Einsatz an der Front so wie
andre eigentlich ist der Bäcker aus
rakev seine Truppe wurde schwer
getroffen
von 24 Soldaten sind zurückgekehrt alle
anderen wurden verletzt oder getötet
trotz der anhaltenden Kämpfe harren auch
noch immer Zivilisten in der frontregion
aus sowie in torske nördlich von bachmut
ein evakuierungsteam der Polizei
versucht die letzten Anwohner in
Sicherheit zu bringen vor allem die
Kinder doch viele winken ab weigern sich
aus ihren Häusern und Kellern wegzugehen
ich will nicht gehen hier ist mein Land
mein Haus auf dem Friedhof hier sind all
unsere Leute begraben ja viele sind
gegangen aber ich will diesen Ort nicht
verlassen
nach langen Diskussionen fährt das Team
weiter doch sie werden wiederkommen und
einen neuen Versuch starten
in konstantiniveca machen sich derweil
wieder Soldaten auf den Weg an die Front
jede Minute sterben Menschen das ist
Krieg sie haben keine Wahl Raketen
fliegen hier immer
auch deshalb hoffen Sie weiter auf mehr
Unterstützung aus dem Westen
die Unterstützung für die Ukraine auch
ein Thema beim ZDF Politbarometer
Matthias frohnhoff ist bei uns im Studio
guten Abend Matthias wie steht es denn
um die so Solidarität der Befragten naja
es gibt nach wie vor eine große
Bereitschaft die Ukraine militärisch zu
unterstützen auch wenn die Befragten
mehrheitlich daran zweifeln dass sie den
Krieg gewinnen kann 32 Prozent finden
man sollte die Ukraine militärisch noch
stärker unterstützen 40% wollen das ist
so bleibt wie es ist und 23 Prozent sind
dafür weniger zu unterstützen
ein Kriegsende ist nicht in Sicht wird
es in den nächsten Monaten Verhandlungen
geben
nur 19 Prozent glauben daran 78% rechnen
nicht mit Verhandlungen zwischen
Russland und der Ukraine zur Beendigung
des Krieges Matthias wie zufrieden sind
die Menschen mit der Bundesregierung und
was trauen sie der Union zu eine knappe
Mehrheit sagt dass die Bundesregierung
ihre Arbeit gut macht 53 Prozent um
genau zu sein eher schlecht finden 41
Prozent wenn die Union regieren würde
glauben 53 Prozent dass das kann
Unterschied machen würde
Verteidigungsminister Boris Pistorius
ist übrigens aus dem Stand Nummer eins
in unserer Top Ten der SPD hilft das
nicht wenn am Sonntag Bundestagswahl
wäre käme die SPD auf 20 Prozent minus 1
cdu/csu 30 plus 3 grüne 19 FDP 5 AFD 14
und Linke 5%, die letzten drei minus 1
das würde reichen für schwarz-rot und
Schwarz-Grün nicht aber für die Ampel
dann vielen Dank Matthias das
ausführliche ZDF Politbarometer wie
immer heute Abend ab 22 Uhr im heute
journal oder aber jederzeit online in
der ZDF heute App
Migranten versuchen immer wieder auf
lebensgefährlichen wegen nach Europa zu
kommen in Bulgarien starben dabei 18
Menschen offenbar erstickten sie in
ihrem LKW Versteck die Überlebenden
wurden in Kliniken gebracht nach ersten
Erkenntnissen waren die Menschen in
diesem Lkw in einem Hohlraum unter
Holzstapeln versteckt woher die rund 40
Migranten kam ist noch unklar nach dem
Fahrer wird gefahren wird
in den Erdbebengebieten in der Türkei
und Syrien ist die Zahl der Todesopfer
inzwischen auf insgesamt fast
44.000 gestiegen denen die überlebt
haben drohen jetzt noch ganz andere
Gefahren es fehlt dann Trinkwasser
Müllberge werden immer größer und
Medikamente knapp experten warnen jetzt
vor solchen Ausbrüchen aus dem
türkischen Antakya berichtet jetzt für
uns Britta Jäger
ein Wettlauf gegen die Zeit nicht weil
noch Hoffnung besteht möglichst viele
Menschen leben zu bergen jetzt müssen
die Leichen schnell raus aus den
Trümmern ihre voranschreitende Verwesung
aber auch Fäkalien und Müll
verunreinigen immer mehr das Grundwasser
die Gefahr vor solchen im Erdbebengebiet
stark
zur kleinen mobilen Krankenstation von
Dr Doku Youtube kommen Menschen im
Moment vor allem mit kleinen
Verletzungen mit rückenhals und
Gliederschmerzen schon nächste Woche
meint er könnte es schlimmer kommen wir
haben hier drei bis vier Orte an denen
wir ausreichend Medikamente verteilen
können momentan brauchen wir aber
dringend mehr Zelte und ganz besonders
mobile Toiletten wenn wir die nicht
haben werden sich die ansteckenden
Krankheiten in den nächsten Wochen
verbreiten
mobile Toiletten und vor allem sauberes
Wasser ist das was sie in Antakya jetzt
dringend brauchen um Kolibakterien
Typhus oder Diphtherie zu verhindern und
die Bereitschaft der Menschen das
Erdbebengebiet zu verlassen Busfahrt
nach Izmir
ich würde gern zur Schule gehen aber ich
kann nicht weil alles kaputt ist ich
möchte zurückkommen weil hier alles ist
was ich liebe ich glaube dass wir hier
alles wieder aufbauen werden deshalb
kommen wir zurück
viele aber wollen hier nicht weg weil
sie der Regierung Misstrauen oder weiter
auf die Bergung ihrer Angehörigen warten
Plätze in den offiziellen zellstädten
sind rar viele Hausen auf der Straße
jeder sucht für sich und seine Familie
doch einen sicheren Ort mein kleiner
Bruder der ist ein bisschen krank der
hat sich heute schon zweimal übergeben
das Erdbeben haben sie überlebt bald
könnten es ernste Krankheiten sein die
weiteren Menschen den Tod bringen
könnten
verheerende Situation auch in Syrien aus
den Erdbebengebieten dort wurden zuletzt
5.900 Todesopfer gemeldet und insgesamt
muss man sagen dringend nur wenige
Informationen nach außen und
gleichzeitig ist es schwer ins Land zu
kommen auch für Reporter unsere
Korrespondentin ist im syrischen
Krisengebiet und steht jetzt in Gin
derdes hallo goline wie ist dein
Eindruck wie schwer gestaltet sich die
Hilfe für die Erdbebenopfer dort
vor dem Erdbeben eine Stadt mit 40.000
50.000 Einwohnern es gab allein hier
über 1100 identifizierte tote das hier
ist eine Geisterstadt es gibt nur noch
Zeltcamps in denen die Einwohner leben
bei Temperaturen nahe des
gefrierpunktetes ich habe das einzige
medizinische Zentrum dieser Ortschaft
besucht hat dort fehlt das an allem dort
hat es in den ersten Tagen nach dem
Beben nicht einmal Spritzen gegeben es
fehlen Medikamente wie
Blutdruckmedikamente Diabetes
Medikamente ist können keine Eingriffe
durchgeführt werden wie z.B ein
Luftröhrenschnitt es fehlt ein
Beatmungsgerät für Neugeborene und dem
einzigen regionalen Krankenhaus dass sie
Einwohner hier versorgt gibt es ein
einziges ct-gerät als sich die Ärzte
gefragt habe ob den überhaupt
europäische Hilfe hier angekommen sei
hat man den Kopf geschüttelt und gesagt
nein wir haben von den Nachbarorten
Hilfe bekommen wir haben ein bisschen
Hilfe bekommen von Saudi Arabien von
Katha aber insgesamt sehr sehr wenig und
es war für uns eine unglaublich belasten
eure seelisch belastende Situation neben
den Trümmern zu stehen tagelang die
Hilfeschreie zu hören und nichts machen
zu können man hat sich mit sehr
einfachen Mitteln geholfen man hat ein
Wagenheber benutzt um überhaupt suchen
zu können in im Schutt und in den
Trümmern aber man fragt sich immer
wieder wir hätten so viele retten können
wäre Hilfe rechtzeitig in dieser Region
angekommen extrem angespannte Situation
im syrischen Erdbebengebiet danke schön
nach den ddes
und das Gespräch haben wir aus
technischen Gründen vor der Sendung
aufgezeichnet den Menschen helfen können
Sie mit
spendenansaktionsbündnis
Katastrophenhilfe IBAN de
65-100 400 600-100 400 600 Stichwort ZDF
Erdbeben Türkei Syrien nachzulesen auf
spenden.zdf.de und im ZDF Text auf der
Seite 89.0
im Iran erklärte das mulla-regime erst
vergangenes Wochenende die Proteste für
gescheitert aber im Land brodelt es
weiter gestern Abend soll es in mehreren
Städten neue Demonstrationen gegeben
haben anlass war die Hinrichtung zweier
Demonstranten die Proteste hatten ja
nach dem Tod von Massa Amini im
vergangenen September begonnen sie war
wegen eines angeblich schlecht sitzenden
Kopftuches festgenommen worden
Unterstützung für die iranische
Protestbewegung auch ein Thema auf der
Berlinale gestern gab es
Solidaritätsaktionen auf dem roten
Teppich das brutale Vorgehen des
iranischen Regimes findet sich auch auf
der Kinoleinwand wieder ein
Dokumentarfilm erzählt einen
justiz-skandal der weltweit Aufsehen
erregte Jörg Blase dazu
wenn ich in diesen Tagen hier in Berlin
gegen das Regime in meiner Heimat
demonstriere nehme ich dieses Bild mit
sagt Jule pacrawan es zeigt ihre Tochter
Ray Hanne und Marcel Amini deren Tod die
jüngste Protestwelle in Iran ausgelöst
hatte
all people als ich hörte dass
inhaftierte Demonstranten im Todes Trakt
auf ihre Hinrichtung warten konnte ich
nachts nicht mehr schlafen nicht eine
Minute es hat mich alles an meiner
eigene Geschichte erinnert
denn ihre Tochter saß auch in einem
Todestrakt von diesem Fall erzählt der
Film sieben Winter in Terran
2007 wird die 19-Jährige zum Tode
verurteilt weil sie einen Mann der sie
vergewaltigen wollte erstochen hatte der
Mann war Mitarbeiter des iranischen
Geheimdienstes sieben Jahre lang kämpft
die Mutter um die Begnadigung ihrer
Tochter vergebens Ende Oktober 2014 war
drei eine hingerichtet für ihren Film
wertete Regisseurin Steffi niederzoll
zahllose Dokumente aus wie
Tagebuchaufzeichnungen Telefon
Mitschnitte und Verhörprotokolle
beschreibt ist
pure Gewalt was ihr da widerfahren ist
und es ist ein ganz Mini kleiner Teil in
diesem Film drin weil ich das Gefühl
hatte dass der Film ist sowieso relativ
schwer ertragbar und irgendwo muss ich
so die Grenze haben was man Zuschauer in
zumuten kann der Film erzählt von Ray
Hannes Kampf im Gefängnis gegen
männliche Gewalt und Vorherrschaft und
vermutigen Kampf der Mutter draußen
gegen ein Rechtssystem das nicht einfach
bestraft sondern Rache nimmt dieser
Kampf ist heute immer noch so aktuell
wie damals
ein Warnstreik an vielen großen
Flughäfen hat heute den Luftverkehr in
Deutschland durcheinander gebracht fast
300.000 Passagiere sind betroffen die
Gewerkschaft Verdi bestreite unter
anderem die Drehkreuze Frankfurt und
München mehr als 2000 Flüge fehlen aus
im Tarifstreit im öffentlichen Dienst
fordert Verdi für die Beschäftigten
10,5% mehr Geld mindestens aber 500 € im
Monat mehr
das Entsetzen über den Angriff auf
Polizisten in Trier ist groß von einem
unfassbaren Gewaltausbruch spricht die
rheinland-pfälzische Ministerpräsidentin
Dreier für die Täter werde es schwere
Folgen haben was war passiert vor einem
Club waren gestern Abend etwa 40
Personen mit Stöcken Schaufeln und
Flaschen auf die Einsatzkräfte
losgegangen Christel Hass berichtet
Glasscherben ein blutiges Taschentuch
das sind am Tag der Nacht die einzigen
Zeugen von dem was vor dieser Disco
passierte es ist gegen Mitternacht
während drinnen die weiberfastnachtsfete
steigt wird die Polizei zu dem Club
gerufen eine Körperverletzung eigentlich
ein Routineeinsatz doch dann plötzlich
das etwa 40 Personen greifen die Beamten
mit stöckenflaschen und Fäusten an erst
als die Polizei warenschüsse abgibt
beruhigt sich die Lage der Innenminister
ist entsetzt diese Enthemmung ist
erschreckend die Skrupellosigkeit macht
auch mich wütend und dieser Gewalt
werden wir selbstverständlich gegen
polizeibeamt in Polizeibeamte nicht
dulden fünf Beamte wurden verletzt zwei
Männer festgenommen nach den anderen
Angreifern wird noch gesucht Gewalt
gegen Polizei das ist kein Einzelfall
das kann neues Phänomen wir haben das
ist an Silvester erlebt wir erleben das
bei Fußballspielen bei vielen
Auseinandersetzungen und wir leben ist
auch bei größerlich größeren
Feierlichkeiten also es kein Exot
besonders heikel Angriffe erfolgen immer
öfter ohne konkreten Anlass den Grund
dafür sehen Experten in der Bildung von
gesellschaftlichen Subkulturen wir haben
zunehmende gegenstrukturen auch bei
gewaltbereiten Menschen man kooperiert
nicht mehr mit dem Staat und wenn der
Staat dann auftaucht dann mobbt man sich
und rockt man sich zusammen und
verbindet sich gegen den Staat die
Polizei in Trier ermittelt nun wegen des
Verdachts auf Körperverletzung und
Widerstand gegen Vollstreckungsbeamte
für viele Schlagerfans ist der bis heute
der fröhlichmacher der Nation Tony
Marshall er hatte einen Staatsexamen als
Opernsänger und beherrschte sechs
Instrumente gestern Abend starb Tony
Marshall mit 85 Jahren im Kreis seiner
Familie Nina koschilden erinnert und
beginnt mit seinem wohl größten Hit
[Musik]
die schöne Maid ist es die Tony Marshall
1971 berühmt und ihn danach zu einem der
erfolgreichsten Schlagersänger in
Deutschland macht Tony Marshall erobert
die Hitparaden verkauft mehr als 30
Millionen Platten
und weiter jetzt mit dem ersten Platz
sie hören bereits im Hintergrund und
wissen worum es geht es geht um Sony
Marshall und komm gib mir deine Hand
dort ist da Dieter Thomas Heck ist es
dann auch der Tony Marshall zum
fröhlichmacher der Nation erklärt
[Musik]
1938 kommt der als Herbert Anton blöd
zur Welt als Tony Marshall wird der
studierte Opernsänger ein Star in den
80er Jahren dann mit eigener
Fernsehsendung im ZDF
[Musik]
und ich mach das gern vor eineinhalb
Jahren dann sein letztes Album gemeinsam
mit seinen Söhnen Mark und Pascal das
Wichtigste für ihn also vereint die
Familie und die Musik auf bald im
nächsten jetzt zu einem schönen Erfolg
im Wintersport mit dir Christina und der
kommt genau richtig den knapp eine Woche
vor Beginn der Nordischen
Skiweltmeisterschaften präsentiert sich
skispringerin Katharina Althaus in
toller Form sie waren in rasnov Rumänien
den Vorletzten Test von der
Normalschanze eine überglückliche
Katharina Althaus der Oberstdorferin
Glück deine überliegender Weltcup sie
dank Traumflug auf 98 einhalb Meter im
zweiten Durchgang sechster Erfolg des
Winters für die Olympia 2
hierher kommen und dachte mir mal
schauen wie es wird ich wollte einfach
gute Sprünge zeigen und ja mein zweiter
war jetzt richtig gut das war er
spannendes Kräftemessen mit der
Weltspitze sehr zu Freude der
Mannschaftskollegen die im Weltcup
führende Österreicherin pinkelnde kann
nicht mithalten liegt am Ende
umgerechnet 6 Meter hinter alt aus die
verkürzt ihren Rückstand im Kampf um den
Gesamtweltcup gelungener Test vor
Planitzer Siegerehrung altaus eingerahmt
von Eva pinkelnik und der Norwegerin
airing wandern
Ernüchterung dagegen bei den Deutschen
alpinen in kursche Welt
parallelweltmeister Alexander Schmid
kommt im Riesenslalom nicht den Schwung
der Allgäuer fand heute keinen Grip auf
der eisigen Piste wurde nur 15 das ist
was ich kann viel auf Zug fahren und
einfach ja das habe ich einfach nicht
ganz erreicht Marco oder mal Zweiter
hinter dem Österreicher schwarze im
ersten Lauf triumphiert im Finale erneut
es waren zwei sehr schwierige Läufe man
musste voll kämpfen und ja ich habe
gekämpft
Silber gewinnt Landsmann mir ja Bronze
Marco Schwarz über Gold aber Streit
Namensvetter oder was
und noch eine traurige Meldung der
frühere Weltklasse starb Hochspringer
Tim Lobinger ist gestorben er lag im
Alter von 50 Jahren einem Krebsleiden
einer seiner sportlichen Höhepunkte 1997
als er als erster Deutscher im Freien
die magische sechs Meter Marke
überspringen als Athletiktrainer
arbeitete er später bei RB Leipzig und
er war auch Personal Coach von
Nationalspieler Joshua Kimmich Tim
Lobinger unvergessen und die
Betroffenheit ist natürlich groß
in der Tat vielen Dank Kristin beim
Wetter bleibt es stürmisch und zu mild
für die Jahreszeit mehr dann gleich von
östen-terli
Verteidigungsminister Pistorius im
heute-journal Interview mit Marietta
Slomka ab 22 Uhr kommen sie gut ins
Wochenende vielen Dank und bis morgen
wenn Sie mögen
[Musik]
schönen guten Abend und herzlich
willkommen zum Wetter derzeit ist es
recht ungemütlich über Deutschland
Sturmtiefs überqueren uns einmal von
Nordwest nach Südost dabei ist auch
Regen und er kann kurzfristig auch mal
kräftiger ausfallen in der Nacht zum
Beispiel von Nordwesten aufkommende
ansonsten nach Osten verlagernd und auch
im Süden regnet es nur ganz im äußersten
Süden bleibt es trocken uns ganz im
Norden zum Beispiel auch Richtung Ostsee
da durchaus mit Orkane artigen Böden
über Nacht ja und die Temperaturen dazu
vier Grad nach Nordosten hin elf Grad
ganz im Westen Deutschlands und morgen
dann erst einmal kräftiger Regen im
Westen der sich ostwärts verlagert und
dann am späten Nachmittag und Abend dann
durchaus auch in der Mitte das wird
nicht viel sein ganz im Süden scheint
auch die Sonne länger das mit einem
kräftigen Wind hier haben wir es mit 50
bis 80 km pro Stunde zu tun also Sturm
die orkanartigen Böden an der Küste die
lassen dann in den Frühstunden
allmählich nach Temperaturen dazu 5 Grad
in Schleswig-Holstein 15 Grad ganz im
Süden maximal viel zu mild die nächsten
Tage gehen mild weiter Sonntag bis 13
Montag bis 16 sogar und im Norden Sturm
ein schöner Abend